GONNA BE THE MAIN BITCH.
THE PRESS FREAKED OUT.
SO, LIKE, GROVER WAS LIKE,
OKAY.
WELL, I WILL BE FULLY COMMITTED
TO A CERTAIN WOMAN,
I WILL BE FULLY COMMITTED
TO A WOMAN
THAT'S MY HUSBAND--WIFE.
[laughs]
WAIT, WHAT WAS I SAYING?
I DIDN'T EAT TODAY.
THAT'S SO BAD.
- WE NEED TO GET SOME FOOD
IN YOU.
- OKAY, WAIT.
LET'S SEE YOU.
OH, HONEY.
CUTE.
OH, I'M SO PROUD OF YOU.
ONE, PLACE
"FROGEN" NUGGETS.
FROZEN.
OKAY.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
- WHAT DO YOU THINK?
- KILLING IT.
[laughter]
- SO, LIKE, THEY DID THAT,
AND THE PRESS
WAS, LIKE, HOUNDING.
LIKE, THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME
THAT SOME PRESIDENT,
LIKE, MARRIED A GIRL
WHILE HE WAS
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
SHE WAS KIND OF LIKE
AN IT GIRL.
LIKE, EVERY TIME SHE WAS
ON A MAGAZINE COVER,
THEY WOULD MOVE MAD UNITS.
IT'S LIKE HER IMAGE
WAS REALLY EXPLOITED,
AND PEOPLE WERE PUTTING HER
EVERYWHERE AND EVERYTHING
FROM, LIKE,
HOUSEHOLD CLEANING PRODUCTS
TO, LIKE,
SMALL PERSONAL ITEMS.
LIKE, PILL BOXES,
WOODEN THINGS,
BECAUSE THEY FELT THAT,
LIKE, YEAH,
THIS GIRL WILL SELL [bleep],
BUT SHE WAS LIKE, WHATEVER.
YOU GUYS CAN, LIKE,
BASTARDIZE ME
AND TURN ME INTO
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS,
BUT, LIKE, ACTUALLY I'M
A COLLEGE-EDUCATED WOMAN.
I'M PUT TOGETHER, AND, LIKE,
PEOPLE ARE INTERESTED IN ME
IN A WAY THAT
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN INTERESTED
IN OTHER FIRST LADIES,
AND I'M GONNA, LIKE,
BLOW THAT UP.
LIKE, IF EVERYONE'S GONNA BE
PAYING ATTENTION TO ME,
LET'S MAKE SURE
THEY'RE PAYING ATTENTION TO ME
FOR THE RIGHT REASONS.
AND BY THE WAY, I WOULD
LIKE TO BE CALLED FRANK.
I MEAN, YOU CAN CALL ME FRANCES
OR YOU CAN CALL ME FRANK,
BUT MOSTLY FRANK.
- THAT'S PRETTY COOL--
A GIRL SAYING
SHE WANTS TO BE CALLED
FRANK.
- I MEAN,
THAT'S THE THING IS,
LIKE, SHE WAS
A DOWN-ASS BITCH.
LIKE, SHE'S LIKE,
EVERY SINGLE SATURDAY,
I'M GOING TO MEET WITH
THE WORKING WOMEN OF WASHINGTON,
AND THERE WOULD BE
LINES FORMING OUTSIDE
OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND FRANCES CLEVELAND, LIKE,
SAW TWO YOUNG GIRLS
EATING OUT OF--
OUT OF
A DUMPSTER ONE DAY.
SHE'S LIKE, THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
LIKE, THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
AND SO SHE STARTED
A CHARITY CALLED, LIKE,
THE HOME FOR FRIENDLESS
COLORED GIRLS.
I'M GONNA SAY, LIKE, THAT'S
A BRUTAL NAME FOR A CHARITY.
[dog growls]
- SHH.
CAN YOU BE QUIET?
WAIT ONE SECOND.
OKAY, THAT'S GOOD.
[dog growls]
BUT SHE HAD ALL THIS [bleep]
GOING ON.